bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour cette édition spéciale consacrée
aux élections régionales au lendemain du
premier tour trois listes sont en lice
le fn l'union udi l air et le parti
socialiste
quels sont les enseignements du premier
tour quels sont les enjeux du second je
vous propose justement est bien de
passer cette émission un pour consacrer
cette émission assez la question sur le
plateau avec nous jérôme durain tête de
liste socialiste bonjour pour la
saône-et-loire julien odoul jour bonjour
vous êtes chef de file pour le front
national dans l'yonne et alain joyandet
chef de file elle est rude et y pour la
haute saône devraient nous rejoindre
d'ici quelques minutes
et puis nous irons voir ce qu'elle
circulait sur les réseaux sociaux avec
vous elle a besoin réaction reprise de
campagne appelle à la mobilisation
nos experts politiques avec nous
également eric sicaud pour interroger
nos invités analysé le vote d'hier et
puis avec vous jérémy chevreuil elle
nous évoquerons la suite des événements
d'autres invités seront également en
duplex avec nous depuis besançon avec
catherine et marie catherine amérique
qui sont les invités qui sont autour de
vous bonjour août bonjour à tous et bien
nous avons trois invités aujourd'hui sur
le plateau à besançon tout d'abord
sylvie laroche conseiller régional ps
elles mêmes vice-présidente sortante
elle était chargée de la formation et
des lycées julia haake art du front
national il est conseiller municipal
d'opposition à besançon et puis stephan
kramer conseil régional lr il est même
le président du groupe lr udi au conseil
régional de franche comté a tout de
suite
merci catherine a tout de suite et alain
joyandet nous a donc rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour merci de nous avoir
retrouvé les résultats d'abord sur
l'ensemble de la grande région bourgogne
franche comté nous allons voir ensemble
de résultats du premier tour la liste fn
conduite par anne sophie montel obtient
donc 31 5% des suffrages devant françois
sauvadet pour lr udi 24% et la
socialiste marie-guite dufay presque 23
22 80
des oeuvres pour être très précis noter
qu'une autre liste dépasse la barre des
5% celle de deux bouts la france menée
par maxime thiébaut il sera en duplex en
direct avec nous tout à l'heure on va
voir à présent en fonction des
départements du côté de la franche comté
c'est en haute saône que le front
national obtient son meilleur score avec
4 37 5% des voix devant le parti
socialiste 23,88 est la rue des 20 89 le
territoire de belfort ensuite le fn
arrive en tête avec 34 points 76 % le ps
27% à l'est rue des 18,76 % dans le
doubs sophie montel totalise 31 points
74 % des voix devant marie-guite dufay
26,09 françois sauvadet 22,78 enfin le
jura c'est là où le score du fn est le
plus faible en franche comté il reste en
tête avec un peu moins de 30% des voix
devant elle est rude et 23h34 lps un peu
3 en bourgogne à un seul département
fait figure d'exception c'est la côte
d'or qui a placé françois sauvadet en
tête côte d'or dont il est le président
du conseil départemental la liste l
érudit atteint 30,8 % devant le fn 27,7
et le psc 22,3 pour le reste dans
l'yonne le front national réalise son
meilleur score en bourgogne avec 36,2
devant la droite 22,4 et le psc 18,4
dans la nièvre sophie montel obtient 31
4 devant marie-guite dufay deuxième avec
24,5 et françois sauvadet 18,1 enfin la
saône et loire a voté fn à près de 28
pour 29% 28,99 la liste elle est rudy
est à 25,1 et celle du ps à 22,9
on vient de le voir la grande gagnante
de ce premier tour c est la tête de
liste du front national sophie montel
alors comment at-elle passé cette soirée
électorale aux côtés de ses militants
réponse avec pascal chaumeil claire
pérot à peine les premiers bulletins
dépouillés où joue du portable au front
national et surtout de la calculette
entre 30 et 32 % des voix en bourse
franche comté et dans certaines communes
un fn qui frôle les sommets partout tu
me diras literie de mes résultats que
j'ai reçus en à 40% sauvé des seize
solidement en tête avec 31,5 % des voix
au final sophie montel est sûre de ses
électeurs pour le deuxième tour
si nous sommes en triangulaire les
chances du front national sont certaines
puisque nous avons la dynamique derrière
nous avec six ou sept points ou 2 points
d'écart avec nos principes notre premier
adversaire derrière monsieur la liste
u10 les républicains c'est assez tout à
fait c'est tout à fait jouable pour le
front national
conçu en tête
il faudra encore travailler car le ps a
des réserves avec les écologistes et le
front de gauche à droite les 5,2 pour
cent de voix de deux bouts la france
sont très convoités pas question
pourtant de tractations d'appareils pour
sophie montel
mais un appel du pied aux électeurs de
maxime thébaux il ne veut pas du front
national à la tête la bourgogne franche
comté ce n'est pas forcément ce que
souhaitent ses électeurs je n'ai rien à
offrir un monsieur thiébaut je me bats
pour mes convictions et avec les idées
qui sont les miennes et j'ai un long
combat politique derrière moi et je n'ai
jamais pratiqué les petits arrangements
entre les deux tours je laisse ça à la
clique ump est ce une stratégie
invariable depuis 30 ans qui portera ses
fruits ou pas dimanche prochain
libé temps nous vers vous et eric sicaud
quels sont les enseignements à tirer de
ce premier tour des élections régionales
en bourgogne franche comté là on l'a dit
on la retire avant tout que les
électeurs ont boudé les urnes il faut le
rappeler seul un inscrit sur deux s'est
déplacé malgré les appels à la
mobilisation c'est une forme de vote de
contestation dans les grandes villes
c'est sens qui bat tous les records
d'abstention plus de 63% à mâcon aussi
61% de verre 60% deuxième enseignement
évident le front national gagne du
terrain avec un score de 31 5 % en
bourgogne franche comté il triple
quasiment son score de 2010 en revanche
son volume de voix est assez proche de
celui des départementales de mars
ils gagnent 15 mille voix soit une
progression d'à peine 9 5%
mais c'est évidemment le mode de scrutin
à la proportionnelle qui lui est plus
favorable que le scrutin majoritaire des
départementales le fn est néanmoins en
capacité de ravir la région et ça c'est
une première
son score est nettement plus important
en franche-comté qu'en bourgogne près de
plus de près de pardon 33% contre un peu
plus de 30 % en bourgogne
et ce n'est sans doute pas une
coïncidence fortuite c'est en franche
comté que le la droite fait son plus
faible score elle y arrive troisième
avec 22%
d'ailleurs le grand perdant de cette
élection apparaît comme étant françois
sauvadet le bloc de droite perd près de
trente sept mille 700 voix par rapport
au mois de mars
la gauche elle aussi voit s'échapper des
électeurs environ
seize mille de moins qu il y a neuf mois
et ce sont avant tout les biens des gens
qui sont tout bonnement rester à la
maison et que chacun des deux camps doit
aller maintenant chercher en vue du
deuxième tour
merci beaucoup et eric vous parliez
justement des électeurs et bien comment
réagissent-ils aujourd'hui au lendemain
de ce premier tour nicolas et
l'andalousie david martin son talent et
leur poser la question dans la
périphérie de besançon montferrand
château dans le doubs deux mille
habitants
ici comme dans la région les électeurs
ont placé le front national en tête du
premier tour avec 32% des voix
douloureux pour certains ce résultat ne
surprend pas la majorité des électeurs
si jamais on revient au front national
on a foutu
qu'est-ce qui vous tracasse longs mois
je qu'est ce qui vous fait peur
visiblement jets peuvent c'est tout on
va revenir comme du temps de la guerre
voilà c'est pas pour le pen
disons que les gens avec l'islam qui
commettent beaucoup d'attentats et ouvre
ses bons les journaux à peine mort est
donc le front national arrive en tête
d'un surplus non pas quoi n'importe
autre fait marquant de ce scrutin
l'abstention ici elle atteint 41% les
abstentionnistes un réservoir de voix
pour les candidats mais ses électeurs
qui boudent les urnes seront difficiles
à combat on n'aura jamais n'obtiendra
jamais d'amélioration je pense qu'ils
pourront ces politiques retrouvez votre
confiance ou est ce qu'ils ont perdu
définitivement je sais pas quand
conclusion mesdames et messieurs les
candidats vous avez du boulot beaucoup
de réactions également sur les réseaux
sociaux et pas uniquement de
personnalités politiques
elle a besoin réaction particulièrement
à ce fort score du front national d'hier
soir oui on commence avec la réaction
d'une ancienne miss france et miss
bourgogne marine l'orphelin avec qui
revient d'un voyage et qui écrit ce
matin 50% d'abstention mauvais
nouvelle un petit peu plus ou un autre
message du site jaime dijon un site
d'actualités dijonnaise réveil difficile
pas besoin de vous expliquer et puis je
termine par un petit clin d'oeil je n'ai
pas pu résister c'est une erreur de nos
confrères d'el c'est hier soir vous le
voyez le candidat françois sauvadet hier
au baptisé monsieur machin chose
de quoi donner de l'eau au moulin à
celles et ceux qui parlent de déficit de
notoriété pour le candidat et je vous
montre ce dernier tweet c'est alain
cornu un conseiller municipal fn de
morbier qui dit défilent notoriété
identique sur le terrain de françois
sauvadet pendant la campagne
merci du convocation a forcément à alain
joyandet ce que vous auriez fait mieux
tendance a sauvé ce que vous auriez fait
mieux bon vous savez c'est pas la
question qui sont je crois que la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi où tant de nos concitoyens vote
pour le front national
je crois que la république reculé depuis
des années j'allais dire presque des
dizaines d'années notre pays
petit à petit se dégradent beaucoup
j'allais dire des millions de français
sont inquiets le chômage la difficulté
des entreprises artisans commerçants le
monde rural vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que beaucoup de villes avaient très peu
voté le monde rural à voter ça amplifie
encore les résultats
le mot le monde rural à voter fn parce
que le monde rural se sent totalement
oubliée donc on rentre dans une nouvelle
société dans lesquels dans laquelle
beaucoup nos concitoyens ont besoin
d'être rassurés si vous ajoutez à cela
c'est un guy depuis vingt ans la dre on
le dit depuis 20 ans mais il ya une
amplification énorme et si vous ajoutez
un stage allait dire les événements du
13 novembre
on ne peut pas dire quand même que les
événements du 13 novembre n'ont pas joué
sûr sûr sûr ce scrutin peut être pas
dans des proportions énormes
enfin quand même donc si on ajoute à
cela cette insécurité de nos concitoyens
on arrive au résultat d'aujourd'hui mais
la jat n'a pas su leur parler à ses
citoyens inquiets c'est la deuxième très
bonne question puisque l'intérieur même
de la droite nous devons faire notre
propre autocritique
vous savez bien qu'à l'intérieur même de
la droite classique il ya un débat est
ce qu'on en fait trop
quand on parle de nos valeurs et
trop à droite est-ce qui est ce qu'il
faut en faire moins ou est-ce qu'il faut
carrément affirmé nos valeurs affirmées
nos convictions
je note juste que les deux candidats des
républicains udi en union au premier
tour qu'ils font le mieux en france
monsieur retailleau dans sa région et en
rhône alpes
je vois bien quand même que ces deux
candidats d'union de la droite et du
centre sont quand même deux candidats
qui sont sur une ligne politique
républicaine très clair très forte qui
parle justement d'une manière très cela
ça valait mais je ne parle pas de
françois sauvadet je parle de la
nationale et de la région du nord mais
d'abord bien sûr mais je pense qu'on a
je pense qu'on a besoin collectivement
d'avoir un discours très clair auprès de
nos concitoyens et donc c'est ce
résultat du premier tour évidemment et
provisions le deuxième tour et reste
très ouvert je pense qu'il faut en tirer
les conclusions pour le deuxième tour
alain joyandet vous étiez chef de file
pour le party les républicains sur cette
élection
en franche comté françois sauvadet fait
trois points et demi de moins qu'en
bourgogne
hier alors même que la franche comté est
une région plus à droite que la
bourgogne par exemple la franche comté
avaient voté nicolas sarkozy au deuxième
tour en 2012 a contrario de la bourgogne
qui comme le reste de la france avait
plutôt voter françois hollande
la question est donc est ce que les
républicains est ce que les candidats de
droite en franche comté ont fait le
boulot notamment vous vous étiez absent
hier par exemple écouter c'est la
troisième bonne question
si je puis dire par rapport à l'analyse
des résultats on voit très bien qu'ils
aient un effet franche comté il faut
regarder les choses comme ça parce que
madame les deux dames qui sont
candidates sont deux personnes qui émane
du conseil régional de franche comté
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
francs comtois ont plutôt peur de la
fusion qui n'inquiète pas les
bourguignons donc dans les deux
résultats on a un effet franche comté
qui est évident puisque ces deux
candidates sont issus de la franche
comté et notamment la candidate ps qui
creusent vraiment l'écart en
franche-comté parce que je crois qu'il
ya un vote franc comtois oui on le
savait le café le plus grand c'est pour
françois sauva les cas un vrai déficit
dans franche-comté trois points et demi
c'est énorme
il est 3eme par exemple
département de haute saône il est dans
le territoire de l'agglo reste lui j'ai
arrêté du nous reste huit jours pour le
faire mieux connaître en franche comté
et inverser le résultat la semaine
prochaine un manque peut-être justement
par rapport au front national
oui bah par l'enseignement de cette
élection je dirais il est clair c'est
que nos compatriotes de bourgogne et de
franche comté ont voulu envoyer un
signal retentissant ils ont voulu dire
la préhistoire politique c'est terminé
voilà cette politique menée par cette
carte ump est totalement déconnectée des
difficultés des problèmes que
rencontrent nos compatriotes ils n'en
veulent plus voilà ce qu'ils veulent
c'est écrire l'histoire de leur région
avec une plume patriotes et avec le
tricolore et cette espérance elle est
porté aujourd'hui par ce film hôtel ils
ont julian d'où vous ne craignez pas que
certes c'est une grande victoire pour le
front national au premier tour mais
c'était déjà le cas au départemental en
mars et au final un seul binôme élus sur
les quelques 130 canton je sais plus
combien d'étrangers exactement en
bourgogne meilleur les ont déjà disparu
parce que c'était dans l'yonne et en
irak a démissionné clairement qu'un
effet deuxième tour quand le front
national est en tête au 1er souvent ça
mobilise les électorats de vos
adversaires
où sont vos réserves de voir ils étaient
réserve de voix qui sont immenses je
dirais que l'armée des oubliés n'a pas
encore donné
vous avez tous ces français qui ne sont
pas payés une participation bien sûr
qu'ils en hausse mais il ya énormément
de français qui ne sont pas allés voter
vous avez des abstentionnistes qui sont
écoeurés justement par dans la politique
menée par l'ump est depuis 30 ans qui
sont dégoûtés donc par ces pratiques
politiques que j'ai condamné à l'instant
qui ne sont pas allés voter vous avez
tous ces électeurs de droite
monsieur joyandet parler des valeurs
mais pas peut-on parler de valeurs de
droite avec un candidat centriste de
l'ue dei qui est communautariste et
européiste
il ya un problème et je pense que ces
électeurs de droite vont se porter sur
la seule candidate qui peut battre la
gauche
sophie montel justement
oui parce que finalement donc c'est une
claque de plus pour le pour le pouvoir
ça pour vous jérôme durain ça s'annonce
extrêmement difficile pour le deuxième
tour non je ne crois pas que ce soit
extrêmement difficile ça va être très
très serré mais je pense qu'on peut
l'emporter parce que la gauche va se
rassembler sur la république et que on a
des gens qui ne se sont pas déplacés au
premier tour qui vont prendre conscience
du risque front national parce que moi
je veux bien entendu tous ces discours
européiste le mps communautariste c'est
un peu se laisser parler les uns les
autres
la réalité c'est tout ça c'est des
baisers cdc des mots creux il ya des
gens qui souffrent économiquement
socialement qui n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent qui veulent faire mal au
système politique ses pratiques qui en
ont ras-le-bol quand notre interviewé
tout à leur disais en apparence valable
c'est accablant mais en même temps c'est
pas avec le front national qu'on va
trouver des solutions j'ai honte que les
italiens ne voulait rentrer a dit guo li
ti les pratiques politiques c'est pire
chez eux
est-ce que les années dans ma gentille
jérôme durain c'est vrai mais du coup je
pense que là il ya quand même un socle
de gens qui vont prendre conscience que
les propositions du front national ce
sont des mots creux ya aucune
proposition régionale
on est sur des thématiques nationales on
a des gens qui sont sur le fond et sur
la forme des imposteurs ils travaillent
moins que les autres ils sont moins
présents que les autres ils ont encore
moins de considération pour les
électeurs et on irait voter pour ceux là
pour se défendre
je pense qu'il va y avoir un sursaut
lorsque cette dernière question s'il
vous plaît aux gens
le premier secrétaire de votre parti a
appelé les listes ps arrivé troisième à
se retirer quand il y avait une victoire
possible du front national c'est le cas
dans le nord c'est le cas en provence
alpes côte d'azur ce sera aussi
peut-être le cas en alsace en tout cas
la direction du ps le souhaitent
pourquoi c'est pas le cas en bourgogne
franche comté le ps prend ses
responsabilités partout pour faire
battre le front national partout il ya
des endroits où notre responsabilité
c'est de quitter la scène et de laisser
la droite face au plan national en
bourgogne franche comté celle inverse
c'est précisément parce que nous sommes
les mieux placés
vous pourrez y m oui nous sommes
troisièmes il n'ya pas dynamique à
droite ils sont en train de dévisser de
pourparlers des semaines je suis désolé
je suis obligé le total gauche va nous
permettre de nous sommes les seuls vous
parlais justement de marie-guite dufay
de la dynamique justement en laquelle
vient marie-guite dufay croit notre
équipe a passé 20 heures hier soir
marie-guite dufay sur la route de dijon
quand elle apprend les premiers
résultats
ouais mais il le front national à 33 oui
mais comme vous m'avez dit c'est les
communes rurales pour la seule femme
présidente d'une région c'est la douche
froide retour au tout début de la
journée
marie-guite dufay vote à besançon parmi
ses voisins
à ce moment là elle n'envisage pas
encore le pire bonne journée la journée
sera longue pour vous mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'il sera encore plus longue
pour moi
à la sortie pourtant le doute est bien
là je sens monter beaucoup trop beaucoup
trop beaucoup trop important du front
national fin d'après midi la présidente
passe rapidement à la préfecture où l'on
calcule en direct les taux de
participation ouais c'est quand même pas
une norme
on a encore du travail à faire pour la
mobilisation
19 heures la présidente fait son entrée
au qg des socialistes ici les militants
le sourire marie-guite dufay sortirait
première des résultats encourageants
mais forcément limitée besançon est
fidèle à sa réputation de belleville de
gauche même si la progression du front
national est quand même très très
inquiétante parce que c'est quand même
inédit de voir 20 % pour le front
national 20 heures les résultats sont
définitifs sept départements sur 8 de la
grande région place le front national en
tête à son arrivée en préfecture de
dijon
la candidate socialiste doit faire face
au feu des questions
notre décision est prise y aura pas de
retrait ce serait démocratiquement
inconcevable qu'une liste qui a une
dynamique se retient
marie-guite dufay ne lâche rien et
compte désormais sur les voix de ceux
qu'elle n'a pu rallier les partis de
gauche et les écologistes pour
l'emporter au second tour il y aura donc
une triangulaire dimanche prochain la
liste de droite elle est rude et ea a
obtenu 24 % des voix conduite par
françois sauvadet donc la deuxième place
si le contexte n'est pas idéal pour
engager une victoire en revanche
françois sauvadet appelés à se
rassembler autour de lui pour je cite
éviter le pire reportage hier soir de
thé ossements et romain yvos dès
l'arrivée des premières estimations les
militants de droite ont pris la mesure
du casse tête
un fn largement en tête une gauche qui
résiste malgré sa deuxième place avec
24% des voix
la victoire s'annonce difficile pour la
liste udi elle est reconduite par
françois sauvadet
non même on est super on pensait faire
beaucoup mieux et c'est surtout cette
vague bleue marine qui nous fait peur
quoi donc j'espère qu'au second tour on
va trouver un moyen pour pour contrer le
front national
21h15 le candidat rejoint sa permanence
dit jeunesse les applaudissements sont
timides les visages un peu marqué c'est
une triangulaire 13 incertaine qui se
profile le second tour en bourgogne
franche comté lors ce contexte
particulier alors que le front national
est en mesure de prendre la région je
mesure la responsabilité qui est la
mienne c'est celle de rassembler pour
éviter le pire il n'y aura de ma part je
veux le dire de ce soir ni
gesticulations ni combinaison qui serait
source de confusion ni retrait ni fusion
de listes la droite espère convaincre
les abstentionnistes et bénéficier d'un
bon report des voix du modem et de
debout la france pour gagner la région
le chômage frappe et je comprends
l'exaspération aussi nos concitoyens
parce que digéré la réforme territoriale
digéré la réforme cantonale digérer
cette grande région
certains l'ont exprimé aujourd'hui en
disant clairement que c'était compliqué
pour eux et je crois que aujourd'hui il
faut les rassurer et les rassurer c'est
d'avoir pendant cette semaine
non seulement les mots mais en tous les
cas montré que l'action est et dans ce
camp et que on est là bien évidente pour
relever le défi
françois sauvadet s'est réjoui que la
côte d'or dont il préside le conseil
départemental les placer en tête au
premier tour il y a vu un message
adressé aux autres départements de la
grande région en vue du second tour
édition spéciale bourgogne franche comté
pour ces élections régionales sur france
3 les réseaux sociaux elsa en ce lundi
la campagne redémarre déjà mais elle n'a
pas tardé à commencer et ce désir soir
regardez ce tweet de nadia abidi en
franche comté n'a dit habib sy soutien
de françois sauvadet
je ne lâche rien tractage cette nuit
avant le meeting demain soir à
montbéliard la gauche vous allez le voir
elle aussi sur le pont à stéphane
guiguet socialiste de saône et loire qui
crée un sobre mobilisez vous et puis
pour le front national c'est la tête de
liste sophie montel qui s'y colle et qui
vous allez le voir écrit en avant elle
veut transformer l'essai la semaine
prochaine merci à la direction besançon
retrouve 4e série et ses invités
catherine est ce que vous invitez et
bien ont déjà repris et aussi la
campagne oui tout à fait et ils n'ont
pas attendu
donc ils n'ont pas attendu d'être
totalement réveillé d'ailleurs
donc reprise très très tôt ce matin on
va attaquer ce débat avec un
représentant de la droite haut saônoise
donc stephan kramer et adjoint à luxeuil
il est conseiller régional et président
du groupe elle est rude et ioukos et
régional de franche comté
on a vu le front national est le plus
fort dans votre département la
haute-saône votre candidat françois
sauvadet fait un score très faible 21%
est-ce que de vos électeurs de la droite
classique sont partis vers ce film
ont-elles et si oui pourquoi le
l'essentiel je pense de nos électeurs et
se fait surtout partie de ceux qui sont
abstenus je crois que le grand gagnant
des élections d'hier soir c'est quand
même l'abstention puisqu'on a plu à près
de 50% de gens qui ne sont pas allés
voter
après quand on regarde les chiffres avec
précision notamment haute-saône vous
regarderez vesoul vous regarderez
luxeuil les bains
françois sauvadet est devant dans ces
deux villes devant sophie montel et
devant donc vous dites vous vous dites
là que vous n'avez pas perdu de vos
électeurs ils sont pas partis au front
peut-être peut-être à la marge on peut
pas savoir ce qui se passe dans
l'isoloir mais vraisemblablement que
beaucoup d'entre nous beaucoup de nos
électeurs de la droite traditionnelle
beaucoup d'électeurs vraisemblablement
du parti socialiste on fait autre chose
faut quand même reconnaître que des
élections au début du mois de décembre
dans le contexte national que nous avons
eu en même temps que pour ce film women
and protect pour tout le monde oui sauf
que sophie montel à un électorat
beaucoup plus captifs et donc quand vous
diminuez le nombre de votants forcément
que le pourcentage de ceux qui vont
toujours voté augmente
je crois qu'il ya pas de scoop sur le
résultat d'hier soir il faut quand même
faire c'est ce qu'il nous était annoncée
quand même depuis des semaines et des
semaines et pas forcément un françois
sauvadet aussi bas sylvie laroche donc
socialiste conseillère régionale
sortante vice-présidente en franche
comté
est ce que vous trouvez pas que c'est un
peu facile quand même on entendait tout
à l'heure jérôme durain représentants
socialistes de bourgueil brandir le
chiffon front national pour mobiliser
les troupes
est-ce que c'est pas un argumentaire un
peu court pas du tout parce que je crois
que effectivement on a bien vu hier soir
qu' une fois de plus le front national
progresse la droite s'effondre que les
cadets vis très clairement
et puis la gauche résiste donc comment
pourrions nous imaginer que dimanche
prochain nous confierions les clés d'une
grande région comme la bourgogne franche
comté dans un contexte d'état d'urgence
un parti d'extrême droite ça n'est
absolument sans imaginer ça si vous
n'avez que ça comme argument à opposer
au front national
c'est quand même un petit peu court vous
n'arrivez pas à convaincre votre
électorat mais pourquoi nous n'arrivons
pas à convaincre notre électorat parce
que la campagne des régionales s'est
fait sur autre chose que les compétences
régionales sur autre chose que les
politiques régionales que nous avons mis
en place le bilan personne n'en a parlé
donc avec un front national qui lui n'a
ni programme ni visage d'ailleurs
puisque les visages des candidats du
front national sont totalement inconnus
à part la famille le pen qui n'a pas de
débat de fond à part le rejet à part la
peur affiché brandi comme comme
programme commandant les conditions nous
avons fait campagne pouvions nous
valoriser non seulement notre bilan mais
notre programme
julie un cas pour le front national vous
dites maintenant au front national que
ce n'est plus un vote de protestation
mais un vote d'adhésion
compte tenu de votre programme janvier
vous demander une adhésion à quoi je
comprends pas votre question pourquoi
est ce que votre compte ne met pas
régionales ce n'est pas concret côté je
m'excuse je m'excuse de ces si vous ne
savez pas lire mesdames mais notre
programme
il est tellement cohérent que c'est ce
qui nous permettent d'être en tête
largement en tête au premier tour
moi j'entends monsieur kroemer et madame
laroche nous expliquait toujours les
mêmes choses alors monsieur kroemer dit
non non on n'a pas du tout perdu tout va
bien c'est à cause de l'abstention si on
est si on est aussi bas et si on est
mauvais finalement une fois de plus une
entend pas le message que les électeurs
souhaitent lui adresser à nos électeurs
en se portant massivement sur la
candidature de sophie montel veulent du
changement
ils veulent rompre avec la politique est
désastreuse et je ne sont pas rompre
avec la politique actuellement des
agents également du bilan de madame
laroche parce que
larouche dit notant la campagne s'est
faite au niveau national et pas du tout
au niveau régional quand on regarde les
dernières études d'opinion on sait que
les enjeux locaux ont fait partie de la
campagne et donc je j'entends que ces
deux personnes se réfugient soit
derrière le niveau national soit
derrière l'abstention pour une fois lui
échapper à leurs responsabilités
quoi monsieur cronin petit je dis
simplement qu'effectivement les
électeurs veulent du changement mais le
changement peut pas être incarné par un
parti politique qui un pendant les six
dernières années à la région a été
marquée surtout par son absence quand on
vient juste pour signer la feuille et
caen sort au bout d'une heure c'est pas
comme ça qu'on peut défendre les
thématiques régionales et la question
qui vous est posée c'est quel est votre
programme vous déviez de la question en
essayant de vous basez en disant que
c'est cohérent mais c'est cohérent avec
quoi faute de preuves il est cohérent
avec la bretagne avec l'île de france ou
avec la normandie aujourd'hui
parlez-nous des transports parlez nous
du développement économique aujourd'hui
vous nous parlez de fermer les
frontières de sortir de la zone euro
voilà le programme c'est pas un
programme régional
le programme qui consiste à parler de
sécurité c'est juste à mettre de la
vidéosurveillance dans les lycées mais
la formation elle est où dans votre
programme pour ça on n'a pas de
programme manifestement comptoir tew
débats thématiques sur lesquelles nos
différents candidats se sont chez vous
d'ailleurs mais la même série a sur
france 3 franche comté france 3
bourgogne sur lesquels nos candidats se
sont exprimés pour répondre à toutes ces
thématiques et je pense que nous l'avons
fait avec était manifestement c'est
cette faction pour nos électeurs
voilà sylvie laroche moi je crois que
vous êtes incapable de proposer d'avoir
une seule idée à nous soumettre là à
l'instant à l'instant même moi je suis
avec marie-guite dufay pour une région
qui porte haut et fort les enjeux de
protection par la formation mais je n'ai
jamais entendu madame montel en cinq ans
nous dire un mot sur ce sujet là je n'ai
jamais entendu madame montel a porté une
seule contribution alors qu'eux mêmes
c'est ces candidats au conseil régional
souvent dormait pendant les séances
redisons le journal mais aucune
contribution
au débat régional et oups olitique
régional gérer moi je suis avec
marie-guite dufay pour une région qui
porte de la protection par de la
protection c'est qu'on va laisser de la
protection avec les enjeux et de
formation à tous ceux qui souffrent
aujourd'hui on sent qu'elle a déjà perdu
les élections dans sa tête alors elles
s'est emballée du coup répondirent la
dernière j'étais de réponse à faire
d'abord sur l'absentéisme c'est
totalement faux l'étude qui est sorti
d'ailleurs par vaux et jerez qu'il nous
reste que quelques ceux d'études qui est
sorti par vos confrères le prouvent nos
élus font pour font preuve d'une très
grande participation au show basé sur
les histoires sur les feux sa maîtresse
j'ai même aller plus loin
madame montel qui est député européen ou
par une retrace bourque un taux de
présence de 99% jouer quatre deuxième au
niveau des députés français venez voir
et je suis sur l'incompétence écoutez
madame laroche pas c'est quand même
insensé avec votre bilan de nous juger
de personnes incapables mais votre bilan
il est mauvais quand vous faites des
formations pour les arbitres les
arbitres de masquer dix ans la dame vous
voulez faire des formations d'arbitrés
de l'assiette en franche comté et demi
vous êtes complètement à côté de la
plaque
à côté voilà on va rendre la parole à
dijon merci madame merci messieurs à
vous dijon merci beaucoup
catherine on peut parler en tout cas en
parlant d' hier soir deux claques pour
les verts il espérait surfer sur la
vague de la coop 21 ans et raté ils ne
siégeront à priori même pas au conseil
régional
retour sur une soirée difficile aux
côtés de la leader cécile prud'hommes
avec laurent dû creuser leur rendre car
dans un kursaal désespérément vide à un
parfum des chèques diffusés par sms
d'ailleurs cécile prud'hommes attendra
d'être à dijon dans les salons de la
préfecture pour commenter son score avec
moins de 4% des voix les écologistes
sorte du jeu a failli perdre et sue est
fait pour moi c'est dramatique et plus
d'écologistes en bourgogne franche comté
parce que on est quand même les seuls à
prendre d'urgence qui m'aide quand
comptez une urgence sociale au moment
même où marie-guite dufay appel au
rassemblement
la candidate écologiste évoque déjà le
second tour nous on va tout faire pour
battre la droite et l'extrême droite
voilà la seule chose que je peux vous
dire pour l'instant après les modalités
on en discute nous entre nous entre eux
qui ont voix près il est alors 22 heures
mais au siège des écologistes
la discussion s'annonce délicate ici la
déception est forte le soutien
automatique loin d'être acquis pourtant
les contacts avec les responsables
socialistes sont pris
la nuit sera longue parce qu'il ya des
dossiers ici qui vous semblent
importants et même incontournable pour
avoir votre soutien à l'agriculture
biologique le développement des énergies
renouvelables le développement du
transport alternatif et puis globalement
on veut appeler à battre le fn on a
quatre heures ce matin
europe ecologie les verts appelé
officiellement à voter pour marie-guite
dufay un mauvais dimanche également pour
l'alternative à gauche union du parti
communiste du parti de gauche et du
mouvement républicain et citoyen sa tête
de liste nathalie vermorel et les
militants sont passés de l'espoir de
franchir les 5% pour pouvoir fusionner à
la désillusion à l'arrivée des résultats
fanny borius et gabrielle talon nathalie
vermorel avait décidé de suivre les
résultats à la préfecture à dijon
arrivés un peu avant 20 heures la tête
de liste alternative à gauche était
alors très optimiste les derniers
sondages nous on nous ont mis depuis le
début de l'été jusqu'à maintenant entre
sept et huit et demi je pense qu'on sera
effectivement dans cet étiage verra à
20h15 les premières estimations tombent
et donne sa liste à quatre et demi pour
cent mais nathalie vermorel croit encore
pouvoir dépasser les 5% mais sûr qu'on
nous dit on est un peu surpris du rasoir
on est un petit peu dans la quiétude
mais je pense qu'on passera les cinq
portions je suis confiante à 21h pas si
vous y croyez encore mais je suis
quelqu'un qui me bat tout le temps
jusqu'au bout et qui croit jusqu'au bout
à mes idées aux idées qu'on représentait
voilà bien sûr j'y crois toujours
de retour à la fédération du parti
communiste transformé en qg de campagne
quelques militants sont là visage fermé
la déception est grande c'est ce que
relate vient pas par miracle c'est pas
pour les beaux yeux de la dame du front
national c'est parce qu'il ya des gens
qui souffrent les gouvernements qui les
entend pas mais qu en rajoute une couche
et c'est toute la gauche qui doit celle
qui doit s'interroger et il faut
reconstruire de fond en comble un grand
projet avec les gens pour une de gauche
une gauche véritable je pense que c'est
la leçon principale de de ce choix il
est 21h30 passées lorsque la liste prend
enfin la pleine mesure des résultats
j'avoue franchement que je pensais que
ce ne serait pas
ce ne serait pas à l'ordre du jour je
suis très déçu pour ma région c'est
surtout ça je me dis que si le fonds
national s'empare de cette région avec
une catastrophe
j'ai beaucoup de craintes pour les
jeunes dans les lycées j'ai beaucoup de
craintes pour la formation
professionnelle j'ai encore plus de
craintes pour le ter à chaque fois qu'on
a voulu faire des politiques qu'ils ont
voté contre mais qu'est-ce qui vous
faire de cette région on va vite dans un
désert on chassera les étrangers c'est
tout sans ambiguïté nathalie vermorel a
appelé dès hier soir à voter pour la
candidate socialiste au second tour
dimanche prochain
jérémy ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas
c'est que et bien dès ce lundi dans
chaque camp on fait beaucoup de
mathématiques et on compte notamment sur
les reports de voix
oui alors pour l'instant à gauche au
moins c'est clair les seules consignes
de vote qui ont été données émanent de
cécile prud'hommes
l'écologiste et de nathalie vermorel la
communiste l on dit tout les deux désirs
soir qu'elle voterait pour celle avec
qui elle voulait d'ailleurs s'allier
entre les deux tours en l'occurrence la
socialiste marie-guite dufay
à droite c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
maxime thiébaut quatrième surprise de ce
premier tour a renvoyé dos à dos
françois sauvadet et sophie montel pas
de consigne de vote nous at il dit alors
on rappelle le positionnement de debout
la france un parti souverainiste nicolas
dupont aignan qui lui même a dit en
ile-de-france qu'il ne souhaitait pas
fusionner avec la liste de valérie
pécresse et qu'il ne souhaitait pas
donner de consigne de vote
alors comme le fn le parti debout la
france a beaucoup parlé de sécurité et
d'immigration
pendant cette campagne mais il rejette
clairement le front national que feront
ses électeurs c'est aussi la clé de cet
entre deux tours hier autant sophie
montel que françois sauvadet leur ont
lancé des appels du pied et puis à
droite y est aussi le modem pas de
consigne non plus si ce n'est d'en
pêcher le front national de remporter la
région
et là c'est quand même un beau gâchis à
droite parce que christophe grudler un
ancien rpr voulait l'union dès le
premier tour avec la liste de françois
sauvadet mais ni françois sauvadet ni
surtout nicolas sarkozy et damien meslot
n'ont voulu de lui lui ont claqué la
porte au nez et aujourd'hui christophe
grudler leur renvoi en quelque sorte
dans la figure et pis enfin et surtout
la moitié des électeurs n'a pas voté
hier donc les réserves de voix elles
sont aussi chez les abstentionnistes à
millions d'électeurs à reconquérir à
part à reconquérir donc pour pour ce
deuxième tour et messieurs tous ces
abstentionnistes c'est autant de remises
en question de vous de vos politiques
comment faire pour aller les chercher
ces gens qui sont complètement détourné
du scrutin alors je voyais en est
d'abord je voudrais après votre
éditorial vous dire que cette à droite
que les choses sont les plus claires et
pas à gauche sauf que nous on est clair
depuis hoffenheim et au personnel et
nous avons nous avons nous une stratégie
qui éclaire un projet compact global
cohérent une équipe compacte globale et
cohérente depuis le début avant le
premier tour
si on nous fait confiance on sait ce que
nous ferons à partir du lundi qui suivra
le deuxième tour la gauche n'est
d'accord sur rien sont d'accord sur rien
la gauche et les verts
métailié les ados etc ils sont arrivés
devant les électeurs avec trois listes
différentes
on voit le résultat donc non les choses
sont simples du côté de françois
sauvadet
on sait ce que nous allons faire il n'y
aura pas de tripatouillage entre les
deux tours parce que toute la
description vous avez fait c'est ce dont
les gens ne veulent plus avec qui on
s'associe avec qui on s'additionnent
avec qui on soustrait nous c'est simple
autour de françois sauvadet il ya une
équipe un projet avant le premier tour
jusqu'au deuxième tour
la seule liste qui est capable de
rassembler et de faire échec au front
national c'est la liste françois
sauvadet pour laquelle j'appelle tous
les électeurs de la droite et du centre
à nous rejoindre pour le 2e rue du rhin
va sans doute nous dire la même chose
pour la liste de marie-guite dufay cayla
solaire en capacité de l ai déjà dit
mais alors il ya 80 mille voix en gros
un pour les écologistes et les
communistes vous êtes sûr de les avoir
déjà d'une dans quelques mots alors
qu'il n'y a pas de fusion puisque perez
a franchi la barre des 5 pour cent
personnes
les propriétaires des électeurs donc
celui qui dit le report de voix il sera
tel ou tel il vous m'en voyez une chose
que je partage avec alain joyandet c'est
que les choses sont simples
françois sauvadet est tout seul et tout
seul il n'a pas de report de voix la
gauche est rassemblée
on a travaillé ensemble pour gérer les
régions jusqu'à maintenant on avait là
le projet d'un accord
on a un soutien explicite du reste de la
gauche les électeurs suivront donc je
pense qu'on a une vraie dynamique
on l'a senti dans les sondages la droite
n'a cessé de dévisser ils sont partis à
30 ils finissent à 24 péniblement on est
un point derrière
donc il ya une dynamique de notre côté
c'est évident et les seuls qui peuvent
faire barrage contre le front national
c'est la gauche rassemblée c'est de
l'arithmétique électorale
moi je crois aussi qu un sursaut je vous
avais parlé longtemps ont joué ce soir
ils m'ont juste un an pam a pas de mots
du coup il ya bien sûr sans succès il ya
un sursaut républicain
plusieurs bons il ya un sursaut
républicain qui permet quand même de
mobiliser les abstentionnistes qui ont
envie de d'éviter front national il faut
dire qu'en mai dernier
il va falloir aller chercher mais on a
là une imposture politique c'est des
gens qui sont plus opportunistes plus
carriériste - travailleurs que les
autres donc un jour les électeurs vont
ouvrir les yeux sur ce jeu c'est un jeu
juste à vous dire qu'à part les joueuses
de jure est juste un mot mais
franchement
écoutez vous avez la présidente sortante
de la région franche comté une fabrique
et bien moi je veux bien qu'on dise tout
et n'importe quoi en terme de en termes
d'analysé électorale
et puis de deuxième tour premièrement
les consignes de vote ça ne marche pas
les gens y sont adultes c'est pas la
peine de leur donner des consignes au
deuxième tour ici et ce qu'ils ont à
faire il faut respecter le vote de
chacun c'est pour ça que je dis que
c'est pas la peine de tripatouiller puis
deuxième chose quand même
moi je voulais pas être sévère avec vous
jusqu'à présent vous avez la présidente
sortante
il ya 80% des gens qui ont refusé sa
confiance au premier tour et l'est où la
dynamique 80% des gens quasiment ont
refusé d'accorder leur confiance au
premier tour à la présidente sortante
on sait très bien que quand on est
sortant quelle que soit l'élection c'est
une force considérable
donc vous êtes en totale décrépitude
avec le parti socialiste
c'est ça la
réalité et l'alternance l'alternance
elle est à droite n'est pas à gauche
julien odoul alors vous allez les
chercher où les électeurs vous avez les
abstentionnistes mais ce que vous faites
un appel clair aujourd'hui aux électeurs
de l'argent s'est relevé comme l'aveu
l'aveu de monsieur qui veut dire nous
avons géré les régions ensemble ce qui
est vrai puisque ump udf et s au lycée
abstrait vela touch que vous vous avez
exactement le même bilan et il est
calamiteux vous comprenez la calamiteuse
et surtout donc je dirais que droite et
gauche du partage fais moi un seul et
même programme
c'est faire barrage au front national
c'est leur seul objectif j'entends pas
parler de chômage
j'entends pas parler de formation
professionnelle j'entends pas parler
d'exclusion territoriale vous allez
faire un appel clair aux électeurs par
exemple de debout la france certains ont
déjà dit qu'ils allaient nous nous
faisons pas appel à des partis nous
faisons appel à ses citoyens les
citoyens c'est à dire que nous avec
sophie montel notamment faire un grand
rassemblement de patriotes qui viennent
de gauche du centre ou de la droite et
surtout les abstentionnistes qui ne sont
pas allées donc aux urnes dimanche
dernier je pense qu'il a beaucoup qui
vont se mobiliser ils vont se dire leur
vote pour une fois va avoir une
incidence et ils sont là cette
alternance droite gauche qui mène à
l'échec et je dirais à l'incapacité donc
je pense que dimanche prochain mais bon
ça c'est des mots tout le monde nous dit
vote utile il ya eu des appels répétés
dans tous les partis même au front
national des appels au vote utile il
fallait voter pour sauver la république
il fallait voter contre les terroristes
et finalement plus de la moitié des
électeurs sont restés à la maison ça
vous ça vous interpelle pas ça mais bien
sûr mais ça nous a cappella ce qui
démontre et nous interpelle mais
principalement ceux qui sont aux
manettes au pouvoir qui sont
responsables de cette incapacité à vélo
vote et ils ont réussi à dégoûter les
français de la démocratie avec les
affaires avec les magouilles avec des
politiques à l'imiter et surtout avec
leur fille leur échelle permanente
essex échec sur le chômage échec sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
échec surtout donc il est normal et je
comprends ces français qui n'ont plus
envie d'aller voter
et moi je leur dis qu'avec sophie montel
ils vont pouvoir donner une vraie chance
à leur région sur les chèques
démocratique c'est évident bien une
crise démocratique profonde elle n'est
pas nouvelle mais je suis entré en
politique après le 21 avril 2002
justement sur ce constat là mais vous
nous dites ça depuis le 21 avril 2000
est justement ce qui va changer demain
donc vu est desservi travail de très
long terme on est dans une transition
économique et sociale très longue et qui
appelle mais on sent une vraie impatient
mais l impatience évidemment les gens
souffrent mais c'est pas avec des
réponses comme celle du front national
qu'on va arriver à résoudre le problème
ils ne vendent que de la haine de
l'exclusion il oppose des français les
uns avec les autres
il ya un problème est-ce que je peux car
minable je suis élu mais il ya aussi un
problème ici grande gueule là public
vous disais tout ça va parler des
régionales
écoutez si on si les journalistes font
correctement leur boulot d'aller casser
les électeurs s'il est si les électeurs
et il travaille de citoyens il regarde
mais les propositions et vous voyez
quand même que quand front national dit
on va geler les taxes dans un programme
régional n'ya pas taxe à la région cc
c'est du flan ils ont un programme
national décliné par tous de la même
façon ça ne tient pas là mais il
s'intéresse par la géo visuellement les
directeurs d'envoi à venir et papa oui
un moment justement sur ce qui est le
plus intéressant c'est à dire qu'est ce
que nous ferons si nous arrivons avec
françois sauvadet à la région en fait
nous allons faire exactement l'inversé
de ce que le parti socialiste a fait
nous allons diminuer les charges de
fonctionnement
nous allons relancer la croissance par
l'investissement la bourgogne franche
comté est la seule région qui est
actuellement en perte de vitesse
dire qu'il n'ya pas de taxe dire qu'il
n'ya pas de taxe
chers collègues socialistes c'est tout à
fait faux puisque vous avez mais il n'ya
pas d'un puisque réunion de novak si
vous avez mis des taxes à fond sur les
produits pétroliers
vous avez la question de la taxe sur les
cartes grises vous avez une différence
entre la bourgogne et la franche-comté
que vous vouliez mettre tout le monde à
hauteur de la bourgogne
on n'a duré que françois sauvadet déposé
un texte de loi pour justement permettre
aux francs comtois ne pas être
complètement
accès avec les taxes aux grisons les
mettant au niveau des bourguignons etc
etc et l'emploi qui sera notre première
priorité parce que nous pensons qu'à la
région si on s'occupe correctement les
questions d'emploi nous pourrons réussir
au plan régional ce que nous ne faisons
pas au niveau national deux cent mille
chômeurs bourgogne franche comté c'est
plus facile à gérer que 5 millions au
niveau national vous aviez deux régions
la bourgogne la franche comté
six départements sur huit vous ne vous
êtes jamais réuni une fois ensemble pour
se dire monsieur ce récit qu'on verrait
pas qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est
monsieur n'avait parlé des six je parle
des six départements socialistes et des
deux régions socialistes
vous ne vous êtes jamais réuni pour vous
occuper on fera linverse en gros france
le sait notre programme il est tout à
fait clair et l'avantagent enfin c'est
comme change pas il changera entre le
1er et le 2e sur le programme ne change
pas et la réalité quand même c'est qu'on
se sauvait des partis pour une balade de
santé avec un programme très léger comme
pour les départementales finalement il
pensait que ça allait basculer
naturellement ils n'ont pas assez
travaillé les électeurs n'ont vu en un
programme solide on a une candidate est
solide et saine qui veut travailler pour
l'élan pour les protéger et merci merci
on va d'abord maxime thibeault dans
quelques instants avant je vous propose
de découvrir le sujet maxime thibeault
et qui est donc le leader du la liste
debout la france qui a réussi à dépasser
les 5% hier notre équipe l'a suivi
maxime thiébaut a de quoi sourire le
parti de nicolas dupont aignan fait
grâce à lui un score de 5,2 pour cent
soit 2 points de plus que la moyenne
nationale
un résultat justifiée par le travail de
terrain selon le benjamin des têtes de
liste on sera à 5,00 et à priori ça ne
pourrait pas baissé donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle je suis content déjà parce que
ça ou demande par rapport à nos autres
scrutins deuxièmement parce qu'on sera
remboursé et troisièmement parce que
notre travail local on a vraiment
labourer le terrain à payer et on doit
certes être résultats aux scrutins et à
l'ambiance nationale l'on doit aussi
notre scrutin notre travail local et
j'ai une bonne équipe derrière moi dont
je suis très content ils peuvent
s'applaudir c'est certain les militantes
aussi de quoi être enthousiaste le
travail de terrain a porté ses fruits
mais aussi la jeunesse semble avoir
convaincu un électorat c'est la volonté
aussi du parti d'incarner le renouveau
politique
et c'est vrai que maxime thibeault est
quelqu'un de compétent qui a déjà en
plus une expérience sur le terrain et
malgré ses 24 ans il est vraiment il est
vraiment excellent il passe très bien au
niveau de la communication
et oui je pense que vraiment ça montre
la volonté d'un renouveau et d'une
rupture avec lycée actuel
autre différence du contenu de la
campagne l'équipe de maxime thibeault
est demeuré sur le débat territoriale
alors que d'autres candidats placés
leurs interventions dans un contexte
plus nationale le fait de proposer d d d
un projet concret pour la région je
pense que ça lui du poids en effet
pendant que les autres partis évincé
cette partie de la campagne régionale
je pense qu'on a fait aussi un petit peu
la différence en tout cas pour les
partis comme le nôtre maxime thibault
sera en tout cas un des hommes les plus
courtisés de l'entre-deux tours
reste à savoir désormais vers qui rompt
ses cinquante mille voix
la tête de liste du parti debout la
france est en direct avec nous depuis
dix jours maxime thiébaut vous ne lisiez
hier soir ici même que la nuit porte
conseil qu'elle constitue y avait donc
vous
au dessus de votre parti debout la
france ce matin à petit souci peut-être
de liaison avec du vent non c'est bon on
vous écoute maxime thibeault m'entendez
oui un bon jour déjà il n'y a pas de
consignes de vote les électeurs sont
libres
bon vous savez je suis je ne suis pas
socialiste
les électeurs sont lui ôter pour qui il
veut le premier tour c'est le temps de
la politique le temps des idées et le
deuxième tour c'est le temps de choisir
un président les électeurs et les
projets regarder les programmes et à
voter pour le meilleur des candidats
donc et vous et vous voterez pour qui
alors maxime thibault dimanche
ah ben moi vous savez il ya le secret de
l'isoloir j'y suis attaché je sais que
s'en tire avec cinquante mille électeurs
que vous avez envie de savoir
je leur ai dit déjà dit je n'avais pas
socialiste donc c est ce qu quand même
déjà une personne la deuxième c'est ils
sont libres ils sont intelligents et son
grand et savent que mon objectif c'est
de construire une droite patriotique
gaulliste souverainiste je suis attaché
à ses idées de retrouver l'indépendance
de la france est au niveau régional
parce que ça a été la démarche de notre
campagne
je leur demande de regarder les projets
de faire comme nous avons fait c'est à
dire de voter pour un projet et de vente
et de voter vent tuellement front
national donc ils votent pour un projet
c'est très important et je pense que le
gagnant de dimanche sera celui qui aura
eu le plus de dynamique
merci maxime thibon direct de dijon en
réaction
alain joyandet julien en double beaucoup
discuté pendant en écoutant maxime
chievo vous avez compris quoi finalement
parce que nous on n'a pas forcément
compris je suis qui va maintenant moi je
sais qu'on fried et je suis conseiller
dans ma conviction c'est que je n'avais
jamais d'ailleurs pris cette position
qui avait un peu choqué à l'époque lors
de la partielle du doubs je pense que
dans un deuxième tour les citoyens sont
suffisamment vraiment suffisamment
adultes ils sont grands c'est pas la
peine de les instrumentaliser alignement
chacun vote en son âme et conscience je
redouble maxime thiébaut nous a rappelé
qu'il était souverainiste et gaulliste
donc je pense qu'il ne pourra pas
appeler vous a voté françois sauvadet
qui est un européiste et qui est pour la
soumission à l'europe de bruxelles
s'il est cohérent normalement ils
devraient voter pour ceux qui montent
elles
écoutez il soutient françois sauvadet
comme la corde soutient le pendu c'est à
dire qu'il ne soutient pas il a appelé à
voter pour un bon projet et je crois
même s'il est passé c'est mon projet
c'est le nôtre donc finalement je pense
que ces électeurs ils peuvent se
retrouver derrière marie-guite dufay et
ils sont très convoités les sapeurs sont
des lecteurs de m'accepter aller sur la
mobilisation à ce qu'il ya justement sur
le fil un appel à la mobilisation a
écouté effectivement les appels au
rassemblement se multiplient un tweet de
liliane lucchesi par exemple la
franc-comtoise je ne retrouve pas le
tweet mais qui appelle un sursaut
républicain autres fuites celui de jean
michel villaumé députés socialistes
franche comté qui lui aussi veut
empêcher le fn de conquérir les régions
et puis un dernier message d'un
bourguignon alexandrie moring du parti
communiste qui dit en franche comté on a
donc le choix la mobilisation ou la
candidate qui croient en l'inégalité des
races moi j'ai choisi ces caches les
temps forts à venir bien sur france 3
point fr pour retrouver les résultats
dans votre département le 19/20 ce soir
le dépôt des listes c'est donc demain
mardi pour l'intégralité des listes qui
seront présentés au deuxième tour noter
également parmi les temps forts le
journal de campagne et tout au long de
la semaine dans votre 19 20 et puis un
débat d'entre deux tours mercredi sur
france 3 merci beaucoup à tous de nous
avoir suivis et passer une très très
belle après midi